The correct answer are it ignores measurements and will likely fail.
It ignores measurements, because the measurement sets the weighting factor
in this resampling process, but with only 1 particle
the same particle will be resampled no matter what.
So the chances of the particle to be resampled is 1.
Therefore, it's independent of the actual measurement.
The robot truly ignores the measurements.
Because it ignores the measurements, it'll likely fail, so works fine is incorrect.
For ignoring robot motion--that's not the case.
Even a single particle can be sampled forward.
So these are the two correct answers over here.